tamare hd resco le cas n'est pas isolé
en fait ya beaucoup de parents qui
pourraient se reconnaître dans ce cas là
qui sont inquiets et à bout de
ressources mais parce qu'ils ont tout
essayé ce qui fait peur quand on voit ça
c'est qu'on dit bon on a tout fait on
les a confiés à des centres spécialisés
encadrer des centres jeunesse et même là
on réussit à les recruter
et ça c'est une tendance que la grc
surveillé qu'il inquiète depuis déjà des
années et regarder le tableau fut une
époque et c'est encore le cas quand même
où s'était surtout dans les hôtels dans
les bars dans des maisons privées ou
dans la rue qu'on recrutait mais de plus
en plus c'est à l'école et aussi dans
ses foyers d'accueil donc ces centres de
jeunesse je parlais une mère aujourd'hui
qui a des problèmes avec sa fille qui me
disait que les enquêteurs et sa morale
ils ont su gérer nos nombreux palais la
dpj et de ne pas confier sa fille parce
que ça risque d'être encore pire
alors on fait quoi dans ce temps-là peut
pas enfermer les enfants on peut pas
bloquer internet dans nos partout de
toute façon donc c'est un problème qui
est extrêmement complexe et qui
malheureusement est beaucoup plus
fréquent qu'on pense ça se limite pas du
tout au québec en fait ça existe
ailleurs aussi pas du tout c'est même
que je dirais je regardais aujourd'hui
les chiffres c'est pire en ontario ce
qui est intéressant au québec qu'on voit
depuis quelques semaines déjà ce qui
part en part on les voit comme cette
dame bon à la télévision le font sur
facebook publie des photos ça c'est
relativement nouveau et beaucoup dit
aujourd'hui mais pour la prévention
extraordinaire parce que ça permet
d'alerter des parents qui n'ont aucune
idée que ça se passe au coin de la rue
et c'est vraiment le cas mais le
problème c'est qu'encore en 2016
on ne connaît pas l'étendue du phénomène
même que c'est extrêmement difficile
encore aujourd'hui de déposer des
accusations et pourquoi c'est si
difficile parce qu'il faut des preuves
et
sans preuve et surtout sans témoignages
de victimes
on peut pas poursuivre et les filles ne
parlent pas notre très difficile de les
convaincre
on peut écouter stéphanie massicotte
elle a pendant des années alors qu'elle
était adolescente est exploité parce
qu'ils ont les énonce pas on peut c'est
comme si un jour à les dénoncer mon
meilleur ami parce que dans notre lettre
ce moment l'heure c'est noémie peut pas
les dénoncer n'aimiez une personne que
tu pense qu'il est l'homme qui veut ton
bien trop aujourd'hui avec le recul
six dépôts sauf que c'était pas des
ennemis mais sur le moment c'était mes
amis je les aurais jamais dénoncé il
veut juste pour le croire en tout cas
moi je voulais pas le croire
et la réalité c'est que même une fois
qu'on réussit à déposer des accusations
c'est extrêmement difficile de condamner
ça fait dix ans que la traite de
personnes à fins d'exploitation sexuelle
est inscrite au code criminel est depuis
en disant il ya eu seulement 85
condamnation imaginer c'est très peu ce
qui fait dire d'où la pression
aujourd'hui de réformer le code criminel
- renverser le fardeau de la preuve mais
ça ça devrait se faire éventuellement
exactement merci beaucoup tamara je vous
en prie